Salut. Après un an et demi de vidéos,
de spectacle et d'écriture de livre,
J'ai décidé de faire une pause cet été.
Pour me reposer : oui,
mais aussi pour vous préparer
une renaissance de la chaîne en septembre.
Je vous avais demandé sur Twitter.
si vous vouliez quelques facts rapides
et divertissants en attendant.
Alors, pendant ces 60 jours de pause,
je vous laisse une vidéo rapide et
sans prétention tous les jours pairs à 11h.
On se retrouve à la rentrée et...
tout de suite.
Salut. Douzième vidéo de cet été,
donc on est le 24 juillet,
et l'idée, aujourd'hui, c'est de savoir
pourquoi le Docteur House,
s'appelle le Docteur House.
[Accent ironique]
C'est intéressant...
Si vous avez suivi un peu la série,
il est clair que c'est un détective
du médical.
Mais ça reste un détective.
C'est même comme ça que David Shore
a vendu le projet à la Fox.
En expliquant que ce serait
vraiment des enquêtes,
sauf que les criminels
seraient des microbes.
Parce que, à la base, cette série
c'était vraiment ce concept là.
Ce n'était pas encore porté
par une personne.
Il n'y avait pas encore cette figure
emblématique que deviendra le Docteur House.
Et quand ils cherchent à construire
le personnage principal,
ils se disent : on va s'inspirer, clairement,
du plus grand détective...
Sherlock Holmes
Et c'est comme ça que
Holmes devient House.
Parce que, Sherlock, si tu enlèves le L
de son nom de famille,
ça fait : Homes
et Homes et House, tu vois le rapport...
C'est la Maison tous les deux.
Et c'est dans la même mécanique
que Watson devient Wilson.
Voilà, on est sur un petit Fact court.
Je vous avais fait une vidéo, d'ailleurs,
de pourquoi Sherlock Holmes s'appelait comme cela.
Si vous voulez la voir.
Elle existe toujours sur la chaîne.
Et puis c'est le principe de cet été
Des vidéos courtes, mais tous les 2 jours.
Comme cela vous avez un petit peu
de contenu pour apprendre quelque chose
ou vous étonner de quelque chose...
Et ça jusqu'au 30 août, donc...
Rendez-vous après demain.
Et n'oubliez pas de liker
et de vous abonner,
si ce n'est pas encore fait !
Ben oui !!!
Profitons-en !
Salut !
[Musique Générique de Fin]